Jordan Peele's record-breaking horror hit
Get Out is a socially conscious thriller that
deals with the worst modern boogeyman of them
all: racism.
With a number one debut at the box office
and a record-breaking performance on multiple
fronts, Get Out is a film to be remembered
— and we're here to tell you its untold
truth.
Fair warning: now's your chance to look away
if you don't want spoilers.
It's not about the president
Get Out might seem like a response to our
current, super-charged political climate,
but Jordan Peele was working on the idea even
before Barack Obama was elected — and afterward,
he was intrigued by the country's so-called
"post-racial ideal", in which people seemed
to believe that a black President represented
the total defeat of racism in the United States.
Peele wrote Get Out as a response — to show
that not all racists look like cross-burning
Klan members.
"The original idea with the movie was to point
out this very real horror we haven't gotten
over."
It's a tribute to classic horror
Peele took inspiration for Get Out from other
scary movies about seemingly well-meaning
people doing horrible things — like Rosemary's
Baby and The Stepford Wives.
But the classic slasher franchise Halloween
also worked its way in — not that there's
a masked killer in Peele's film, but both
movies make the white picket fences of suburbia
look awfully sinister.
Jordan Peele dreamed up the film's scariest
scene
Grab a fresh pair of underpants, because we're
about to relive one of this movie's freakiest
interludes.
This secret behind this creepy moment?
It's straight out of Jordan Peele's subconscious,
based on a dream he had about walking through
a room of people who all fell silent as soon
as he turned the corner — which makes this
scene literal nightmare material.
The original ending was much darker
If you thought that the siren and strobe light
in this scene meant the cops were coming to
take Chris away, you're in good company — with
the film's director.
"The first ending that I scripted was not
as happy."
Originally, Peele ended Get Out with Chris
taking the fall for murdering Rose's family
— but fortunately, he changed his mind,
deciding that it made more sense for Chris
to come out on top.
"I was so excited when I was able to go get
the money to go reshoot the ending that I
knew would really work.”
It's a record breaker
Get Out was an instant success at the box
office, taking first place in its opening
weekend despite strong competition from both
a beloved superhero and a film where Samuel
L. Jackson battles a giant gorilla.
But more importantly, Jordan Peele is the
first African-American writer and director
to helm a debut film that made over $100 million
— and Get Out hit that benchmark faster
than any Blumhouse picture in history.
It's in the zeitgeist
Rave reviews and box office records are all
well and good, but the true measure of a movie's
importance is whether it spawns a meme — like
the Get Out challenge.
Don't worry, it's not as scary as it sounds
— but it is harder than it looks to recreate
Marcus Henderson's fancy footwork in this
now-famous scene.
Casting controversies
Get Out has enjoyed nearly universal acclaim,
but leading man Daniel Kaluuya faced some
criticism from fellow actor Samuel L. Jackson:
"I tend to wonder, what would that movie have
been with an American brother who really feels
that.”
But Kaluuya responded by pushing back against
the false notion that he hasn't experienced
prejudice.
In his words: "This is the frustrating thing,
bro — in order to prove that I can play
this role, I have to open up about the trauma
that I've experienced as a black person.
I have to show off my struggle so that people
accept that I'm black.
No matter that every single room I go to I'm
usually the darkest person there.
You know what I'm saying?
I kind of resent that mentality.
I'm just an individual."
The hidden meaning of milk
Allison Williams is a vision of pure evil
in this scene, scouting for new victims while
eating Froot Loops and sipping from a tall
glass of milk.
But two weeks before the movie came out, a
group of white supremacists did their part
to make this moment even creepier, when they
hijacked a political livestream by actor Shia
LaBeouf and started chugging gallons of whole
milk to demonstrate their white pride.
Jordan Peele wasn't aware when he wrote this
scene that milk would become such a fraught
symbol of racial hatred, but it definitely
upped the ante on the horror.
Jordan Peele has big plans for more horror
He might have started out in comedy, but Get
Out's director reportedly has a lot of ideas
for more movies in the genre he calls "social
thrillers":
"You know these movies that are creepy, but
humanity is like the creepiest part at the
center of it."
Details of Peele's next project are still
under wraps, but he says he's got a whole
series of horror films in mind that will tackle
similar subject matter — and that's definitely
something for fans to scream about.
[Screaming]
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!